Does everything happen for a reason?
So I got a great question from one of my Facebook fans
(love you guys!) Domenic, who wrote in to say
“Evan, hello! Wishing this finds you well.
Just curious, what are your thoughts on that famous line
“Everything happens for a reason.”
Are you in support of it? I’d appreciate your input when time permits.
Thanks. -Domenic”
So thanks for the question Domenic.
This one…
this one stressed me out.
Trying to think of an answer
and I was walking outside for longer than usual
trying to think of where I stood on this
mostly because I don’t think about this a lot.
You know, if you ask me about raising capital
or marketing or startups or web or technology
stuff that I live and breathe every day
it’s easy for me to come up with answers for you.
This one is not part of my daily
Routine.
You know, I don’t say that line to people and so
it hurt my brain to think of
the answer for you.
But you asked for a video response
and so
I’m going to give it to you regardless.
How do I feel about it?
What I like about it is the uplifting
positive
“believe”
message in it, right.
Usually you say
“Everything happens for a reason”
when something bad happens, right,
at least that’s my view of it.
When something really good happens I guess you could say
“Everything happens for a reason”
but it’s more when something bad happens;
when your company goes down
when your dream gets crushed
you know, something terrible happens in your life
or business you say
“Well, everything happens for a reason.”
And you use it as an encouragement to that person to say
“Hey, you know, you’re going to bounce back.
Things are going to happen.
Keep the faith, keep believing.” right,
that’s the uplifting message.
So I love that component to it.
What I don’t like about it is giving up.
At least in my view
giving up the personal accountability
or responsibility
like things are just going to happen for you
without you doing anything, right.
You want your dream to happen you got to work hard at it.
You got to put in effort and hours
and labor and you’re going to go through crap
to get there and a lot of bad stuff is going to happen to you
in your life and your business
to get your company off the ground.
And you look at famous entrepreneurs
who went from nothing to creating billion dollar empires
and they often went through years
of terrible stuff happening to them
and them seeing zero growth and people telling them to quit
and somehow they kept going.
And they did that because they
they were a little crazy.
You have to be a little crazy to be an entrepreneur
and they believed in their idea so much
and in the potential that they kept going.
They really had to do this and that’s what helped
them become super successful
even though it was all failure at the start.
And so I liked the uplifting positive vibe to it
you know; everything happens for a reason
you’re going to get there.
But I also think that if you want to become successful
you got to put in the work
you got to really love what you’re doing
you got to be really committed to this project
and that’s what’s going to help you take off.
So I don’t know if that answers your question
but I promised you a video response
and so here it is.
But at the end of the day, honestly,
I don’t have a super strong opinion on it.
It’s not a part of my
day to day vocabulary or thought process.
And so, anyway,
those are my thoughts.
If you guys like this video
you can support me
by clicking on the link in the description.
Leave a comment
and let me know what your thoughts are
on that famous line
and maybe that’ll create some interesting discussion
on YouTube and I look forward to
hearing what you guys have to say.
And click on my face,
subscribe to the channel.
Thank you so much, I’ll see you soon.
Subtitles by the Amara.org community